cuéntanos qué es la justicia climática y
cómo se está discutiendo esto en la cob
buenas noches muchas gracias por el
espacio la justicia climática
básicamente parte de reconocer que hay
emisores históricos de gases de efecto
invernadero así que sabemos que no todos
los países contribuyen de la misma
manera al calentamiento global y que de
hecho son los países más vulnerables
quienes han contribuido menos entonces
este esto se aborda bajo el principio de
responsabilidades comunes pero
diferenciadas' presente en el acuerdo de
parís y va a ser un tema álgido en esta
cop16 porque se discutirán temas
relacionados al financiamiento por parte
de países desarrollados a países en
desarrollo y pérdidas y daños bueno
usted no se estaba hablando del poder de
negociación o más de que del poder de
negociación de reconocer a los emisores
históricos y que será un tema álgido
precisamente a propósito de esto que
tanto poder de negociación tienen los
países en vías de desarrollo o los
insulares que como ustedes lo decía son
los más afectados por la emergencia
climática a pesar de que son los que
menos contaminan
bueno yo creo que
la conferencia de las partes pues es un
proceso de negociación donde 197 países
pues digamos hacen parte de las
negociaciones verdad pero para hacer un
poco el proceso más fácil y digamos
también resaltar las voces de los países
digamos que son más vulnerables o que
tienen ciertas características en común
se forman grupos de negociación por
ejemplo colombia hace parte del aila que
es la alianza independiente de américa
me acuerdo muy bien nombre ahora pero
hace parte junto con 8 países en total y
esto les da más visibilidad y posiciones
digamos más cohesionadas frente a las
negociaciones
y precisamente a propósito de estos
grupos que se crean usted cree que se
puede esperar que de la cob 26 surja un
compromiso real y más ambicioso o como
lo dijo el secretario de la onu antonio
guterres
el optimismo ambiental no existe
[Música]
yo creo que definitivamente si hay
posiciones muy progresistas de parte de
estos grupos me gustaría que recordemos
un poco lo que pasó hace varios años con
el grupo de países de islas por ejemplo
las islas del pacífico que realmente
presionaron para que el acuerdo de paz
de parís tuviera la inclusión de los 1.5
grados centígrados entonces creo que es
valioso creo que esta presión funciona y
creo que esperamos que la presión de los
países en desarrollo y estos grupos de
negociación puedan digamos tener
resultados contundentes en temas
relevantes como pérdidas y daños y
financiamiento
de 2020 2025 y despues de 2025 y soy
positiva creo que pueden suceder cosas
importantes